do you find  good guys to be interesting  i don't  being a bad guy  kind of comes easy  bad guy's more entertaining i think  maybe that's just me maybe i just like  the bad guys flamboyant arrogant with me  what you see is what you get  [Music]  you can't have a good story  without a great villain  the best evil character is someone that  the audience genuinely fears  the perfect formula would be the  greatest good guy ever  to being the most evil villain  you don't make children cry period sasha  banks running around with that hitman  sasha banks does though  [Applause]  in this eight-part original series  they killed everyone we'll go behind the  curtain when you look into my eyes you  can tell that i feel it so you feel it  and inside the minds  greatest villains in wwe history  to see what makes them so good  at being bad  i'm not playing a character i am the  character  [Applause]  you